hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space - okay we I
remember what's going on
this part
but I got counter to your Bosch
nothing's gonna get the jump on me
mine's
ah gotya
[Music]
not that one off you think they're in
sequential order another one
it hit some where the bodies
[Music]
their chins they behind me just in case
I hit myself I'm gonna edit go away get
song oh god they're climbing over the
walls
ah oh how did I know
get it yeah
we're gonna start
come on come on no comeback
walk into my trap
watch this sticks move by hopping up
there now get through come on
you want a piece of me
oh yeah like it Garner's
[Music]
much health driveway
none that's reassuring as that one's
still on tripped
I heard that
come on let me pick up that one there I
knew it had something huh
Oh
ah yeah suck on that oh no no no - Pro
wait wait that's too close
oh ah are you there get back yeah yeah
that's all one
[Music]
give me two three detonator - okay be
good dad get them probably got to be
safe
heard that
[Music]
I'll be back now
I can't believe that Tom accidentally
hit myself with one it didn't kill me
Wow
nope not today on that is that a ruby
thank you very much I was a firestick
right there
ah yeah oh yeah whoa secret shell
expertly handled that whole room fro
except all the times I screwed up who's
a pro from top to bottom I am obviously
the best something not this game
all right making my way down more of
those goofy oops
[Music]
aha
Ben there we go oh god they're
everywhere
oh right there too
to deal with people I cannot throw line
ah hell did you come from
waitin yes wait okay now there's a store
and I can enter it unmolested Flavio
secret shells semiconductor I seem to be
getting a lot more semiconductors than I
ever did in the last game okay good on
that mostly good on ammo across the
board seems to be the quickest together
it's also the cheapest a my opinion the
most efficient I did that Lou I don't
need any more than that and once they're
gonna throw a boss at me but they might
be concerned with the store in the safe
point right here but I'll take it in
stride and I'll be okay with whatever
they throw I got my gum they ain't got
no
there's a giant tentacle blocking a
transmitted or it's wrapped around a big
tank a big tank nitrogen trichloride
it was exploded the heat of course oh
isn't that convenient what I got throw
these up huh nice convenient little
level you got on the side there what do
we do now I'm out of fire sticks
detonator well oh here fire stick
dispenser vote more more please please
sir I want some more pretty please
oh come on do you wear hey baby don't
leave me please don't leave me I'm so
scared
and also it going insane oh I see you
another time fire stick idea
oh you're not supposed to be there
you're the big guy with the four days
stasis yeah Oh give me that
just one mine really why that's another
one I wish I had a pack get some
detonator oh that's not gonna be good
ah get away no way you know why I get
away oh you know I have no space come on
okay don't stand in the elevator when
you're fighting or else you'll get
cornered and you'll get pwned how it
yeah yeah yeah wrapper on Victor Kimi's
please why am i all reloaded here I
don't think I am WOB then I can go down
if I can beat you to it that means I can
get
but he's there that's him
those are just bouncing off
ah no I have gotten help now that I
think about it that would have been the
smart thing to do now while you're
crippled excuse me while I just I miss
really badly
ah ha ha ha muttered I know ha ha why do
I miss why do I miss because I'm an
idiot
that's why I'm an idiot and I'm an
a-hole I'm gonna die give me one more
please please give me one more please no
no no no no no no I'm in bed get yeah ok
guy the way yeah ah
come on get up there fast this way
please
yes yes yeah up we go
yeah pwned you bro got you hardcore oh
not another one
Oh get on the ship okay
ah explosion epic action go go go oh man
faster what we're gonna make it just
start run yeah double fire
I would think that at that point the
glass of chatter and the situation might
admire your persistence mr. Parr
everyone on this station
sounds like someone's size complex at
this point it's all just dead weight
Isaac what did he mean what did he mean
when he said dead weight oh you know
Thor penis we gotta stop the transport
now I mean that thing that i reactivated
how could even direct them that seems to
be like going straight down just do it
Ellie hurry be a storm or if the gravity
tethers are still functional I can cuz
they go second drag him back I think
this is ridiculous if I can line the
tracks up just for a few seconds you
should be able to get the transport
across stay ready I'd take care of
straws I have no idea what he was
talking apparently I'm going back to the
a shimmer this seems like just a sort of
shoehorn plot device to get me back onto
the Gemara
oh no and I'm practically dying 180
Bebop
Spike's gun was unless I probably if I
hit him right on the yellow
nice and gentle
on that kit thank you it's like some
sort of cleanup thing oh gosh
bad move chapter 10
[Applause]
that should still be a computer in the
flight lounge I can check the ship
status from there are you okay you found
a little nervous last time I was here
things didn't go so well yeah not so
well are you kidding me
all right yeah I hear be moving actually
considering that you trapped on a ship
full of hostile aliens I'd say things
went fantastically well that you are
even alive oh if it's the same layout
then hahaha
here are the lockers those lockers oh
and if I go that way that's where oh if
I went that way even got the vents
locked oh that's where this is the same
this looks like the same
docking bay that we entered and exited
the ship in dead space and if I'm right
there's a safe way right up here what no
no no it was there it was it was not
there all right
that's all the time I got for this
episode thank you guys so much for
watching and I know you guys are looking
forward to the next episode the return
to the issue Mura dun dun dah I'll have
to wait till next time thanks again
everybody see you in the next part
bye bye